thank you for our sponsor hosting er
baby beignet they're offering you guys
up to 91 percent off yearly web hosting
plans 91%
that's almost fle for a limited time so
I want you to go on hosting or comm /jk
news and use our code
JK news if you need a website hosting it
is a great option for web hosting they
have a intuitive user interface and you
can understand this immediately even an
idiot like me can go good but looks so
easy the pricing is affordable compared
to all others on the market while still
having amazing speed that's important
you need fast speed and what's also
pretty cool is there's a lot of support
so they have articles and videos and
tutorials on how to like maximize your
website with SEO and things like that so
you can understand more aspects of what
you're doing with your website they help
you grow and learn you can succeed
faster with hosting and best of all they
offer a 30-day money-back guarantee so
go to hostgator.com /jk news and use the
code so you can support the show and get
up to 91 percent off of your web hosting
and don't forget the code is JK news JK
news all the stuff is in the description
a link in the description the
description below make it easy for you
just click that see you guys next time
they give for sponsoring us hosting her
[Music]
and you are not alone news you are not
but you're together just got it
now was nothing submitted by dear mama
Betty Jeff a mom's Facebook post
defining on the way friends goes viral
on the way friends oh I guess like on my
way or like on the way like I'm gonna
have a party that we're on the way
that's what I thought
yes what's going on so this Facebook
group for moms I hate it already it's
just you're just getting away
no I might go ahead let it go Nicki I
want to know I have all right yes so
this Facebook group
it's called hoes before Bros it's a
Facebook mom group called Northern
Colorado moms blog and so one of the
administrators of this blog in your area
kind of thing thank you for specifying
because it made a huge impact good [ __ ]
better name I wish it was like we
Michael Jackson's innocent mom group or
something at least that's a little yeah
but then what if they're like all over
the world and they want to meet people
in their own hair okay good point put a
deal tag on it
I don't know how Facebook groups work I
don't know either but something better
than this sucks
title anyway they've posted so one of
the administrators who wanted to remain
anonymous she posted this photo so
here's why leaving the photos boring I'm
sorry go ahead
judge full judgment yes like Oh on the
phone and then over here is another
woman washing dishes and then I will
read to you the post what is it so sad
looking so this is what it says this is
what friendship looks like I am
currently walking through the hardest
season of my
and have and as mamas we feel like we
always got to put on our big-girl pants
and just muscle through never let him
see you sweat right
oh girl if there's one thing this season
has taught me it's that that sort of lie
is terribly dangerous to believe I
needed my people today I thought I just
needed to call him up and cry about what
was happening and then while on the
phone my sweet friend asked me such an
important question she asked me to just
say what I needed and wanted the most I
told her that I didn't want to be alone
her response I'm on my way I started in
with with all of the reasons she
shouldn't or she couldn't and shouldn't
come my house is a disaster I don't want
to burden you it's such a long drive
her response sister I don't care about
any of that you said you don't want to
be alone so I'm coming not only did she
make the trek from Greenlee to Fort
Collins but she picked up another sweet
friend along the way they picked up
lunch they walked into my house gave me
the biggest hug and asked what can we do
my disaster of a house they helped me
clean it and assured me it wasn't that
bad they let me cry they let me laugh we
listen to music and most importantly I
wasn't alone mama if you're going
through a rough season know that you
don't have to do it by yourself you
don't even you don't even have to know
what you need just start by asking not
to be alone I know that I know there is
someone in your life who will say to you
I'm on my way if only you desk and Mama
if you have a friend who you know is
going through it just offer to come and
be there with her actually don't offer
just tell her you're coming because I
guarantee she wants that more than
anything and she's having a hard time
being able to say it praying for all of
you walking through the rough roads
right now whatever that may look like
for you know that you're not walking it
alone
we love you mama and for those of you
don't know just seasons what she's
talking about
basketball season stop right now
especially if your nuggets fan that's
hard to that's not true yeah yeah so
this post went viral on Facebook yeah I
bet you I bet you everyone in that group
is why probably in Colorado especially
in northern Colorado yeah mm-hmm that's
what that was code for the white moms
they don't because they don't bother the
[ __ ] out of each other with with this
family stuff mm-hmm
maybe because they do bother each other
the stereotype is people a minorities
like to pawn off their kids to family
they have no shame in asking bring your
ass over here a [ __ ] fix my house and
if I can take care of my kids
big families that's a big family staring
okay yeah cuz that's how I feel he's
saying if you had your family coming
over and doing that univille you
wouldn't know you wouldn't need that
yeah yeah well like I mean like I don't
know their needs like five translator
she also she's also listen Colorado so
she doesn't have family like people that
live in Colorado they can't afford
California right so they're the only
ones moving over there all my friends
are moved to Colorado they're like I
wanted a house in California can afford
so I'm moving over there with who by
myself it's a bunch of low hell a lot of
them they also pretend like they don't
like California they like call raw
better for some reason and I'll pretend
you're pretending pretty well it's cuz
it's cheaper it's kind of like when you
go to a shitty restaurant and you got a
deal and it just the food tastes better
because it was cheaper I got a party you
moved to Denver and he's like Oh with
the air and all gentlemen the airs did
come on no I mean there's no smog but
you still can't breathe there's no
oxygen
everyone has nosebleeds over there do
you have pulse nights over there
nosebleed why aren't there
what happens it's 10:00 it's 10:00 at
night I want to order some Thai food no
you do nope that's I can't move there
they got Thai food everywhere I think
food you can't even go to my hometown
Santa Barbara in order about at 10:00 at
night because it's only pizza left
I like Hartford chicks to like ask for
company to come over and like I think
for like four dudes it's like hey you
want to go play basketball or you want
to go do whatever and I feel like it's
so easy for dudes to just hang out with
each other yeah when you're a mom like
you're the caretaker you're nurturer
like you you know like busy other women
are being so stubborn
yeah exactly it's more like you don't
want to burden people you should be a
little more selfish well I think guys
are also
we have this thing the other way where
we don't want to ask for help right yeah
that is [ __ ] true I'm like hey
honey we should hire movers to move our
entire apartment for help I can't wait
to ask for help broke his [ __ ] back
leg lifting he's like oh my [ __ ] back
you could have moved for like a week
what are you absolutely talking about
for a week what are you talking about I
was I was doing [ __ ] I was I was going
to home people every day after we moved
in brother you could ask for help I
would have hired someone for you thank
you
I want to say yeah if you go can you
take to the airport I'll send an uber
yeah exactly
well that that doesn't exist anymore
because of uber that used to be a thing
though so hey can you take the airport
yeah we see each other apart like 4:00
a.m. that's true
yeah because it was actually a thing it
was like yo I'm not spending Harden $6
on a taxi Kim taking the airport in like
yeah oh yeah yeah so the response to
this this post here she was overwhelmed
because a lot of people were like oh my
god yeah it's like this is exactly true
like a lot of people find it really hard
to ask for help or like yeah and then so
she ended up coming up cuz she says like
I posted this with the full intention of
remaining anonymous but after seeing the
responses pour in and cheering so many
of you walking your own hard hard road
or along someone else's I think it's
important to take another vulnerable
step forward so she ends up coming out
and saying like my name is Kim and this
is me getting through some rough times
so apparently she is is like recently
divorced
and so that's her problem she didn't
have it such a [ __ ] then right yup yeah
I didn't say it you did move out right
around I lost him yeah so she's a now
like a newly single parent and so she's
saying that the days spent without her
son are really difficult to that day she
didn't have her son with her and so
that's why she was telling her friends
like she's lonely be alone right now
yeah that's that these were friends she
met through this forum where she
actually met them in the room that's
cool so she was saying like you know
don't be shy like reach out especially
like join Facebook groups that's true
you need things like that because
back then it took a village what what
you got a rubber band around your head
it's relaxing because you had uh you had
a bunch of friends and family that
you're kind of stuck with and you know
like I feel like people just had long
term as groups and friends we're like
now everyone just moves around like real
quick and they're away from family and
all that [ __ ] they're isolated now
people don't really have roots anymore
yeah people work from home like they
might not even like work where they're
interacting yeah on a daily basis
yeah all of a sudden like you're in the
East Coast because it's just cheaper and
there's a better job yeah yeah but all
your friends like and family is an organ
or whatever I've have been to my cousin
actually the one that lives in Florida
like she's out there actually has no
family out there yeah who do you lean on
yeah so she tells me like it's really
hard to make friends and like it's
really hard to miss you to build social
skills do you have them it's just hard
especially as a grownup because like I
think for me I mean even for me it is
harder to connect with people as you
older really yeah a good connection like
someone that you actually relate to it's
hard I think but yeah not only that but
then they I guess I this post kind of
spoke to me because um like even though
I have you guys like you guys are all
busy you all have your own life I told
you specifically I [ __ ] take Isaac
but you are afraid of what I would say
to him that's not true hurting you is
it's never a burden I'll take them gold
card and I'll [ __ ] make videos with
them no I'm waiting for a friend that's
a kid you go play with especially now
now more than ever I have time yeah okay
I'll take them two sides it's not even
just that it's actually cuz we barely
have enough time with Isaac to because
he goes to school during the week after
school it's like three hours we see him
and then on the weekends he goes his
dad's so we barely even get to see him -
so you're trying to cherish the time
exactly and then that's the best thing -
like with you guys like you know you
have your family time type of time and
stuff and then you're just so far away I
told you I come over any time you want
and you come or dark poisoning time yeah
you know that then it just feels weird
like that's why I relate to him come
over to Michael's all the time I love it
see that that part
you've got these weird like meetings
with each other and I can we don't get
invited to it lasted to go camping John
I'm not going movin there's no running
water [ __ ] yeah because no because
this cat's all over me like oh I thought
you wanted to go shooting guns I I have
to be able to take showers I've said
this he's got a bucket of water a shower
yeah nobody said it that [ __ ] you said
we want water no running with no running
water
let's go up but I have a rinse kit that
you could spray yourself down behind the
tree so you can make the water run on
itself
yeah I get wet wipes and rub my balls
and everything and throw it away good
source cuz you also say you only push I
know I don't let it drip I scrub but I
use a shampoo and I saw cut in the ocean
water do thorough washes when I go to a
hotel because they have those little
washcloths and I put the soap on and i
scrub really thoroughly it's just a
small towel how do I get that dirty have
you respect your neck oh my bad let's go
Burnett next time is crazy you're
actually the same sheet is Steve and you
don't even know it I I wash my face now
Oh like with the scrub no but like how
recently is now I do it two times a day
starting last month
cuz my skin's getting old and [ __ ] up
[Music]